SAL: I've done a bunch of videos
where I use words like
pressure and-- let me write
these down-- pressure and
temperature and volume.
And I've done them in the
chemistry and physics
playlist. Especially the physics
playlist, but even in
the chemistry playlist, I also
use words like kinetic energy.
I'll just write e for energy.
Or I use force and velocity.
And you know, a whole bunch of
other types of, I guess,
properties of things, for
better or for worse.
And in this video what I want
to do is I want to make a
distinction.
Because it becomes important
when we start getting a little
bit more precise, especially
when we get more precise in
thermodynamics, or, I guess,
you know, the study of how
heat moves around.
So these properties right
here, these are
properties of a system.
Or we could call them
macrostates of a system.
And these could be
macrostates.
So for example, let me make it
clear, when I call a system,
if I have some balloon like
this, and it has a little tie
there and, you know, maybe
it has a string.
This has these macrostates
associated with it.
There is some pressure
in that balloon.
Remember that's force
per area.
There is some temperature
for that balloon.
And there's some volume to
the balloon, obviously.
But all of these, these help
us relate what's going on
inside that balloon, or what
that balloon is doing in kind
of an every day reality.
Before people even knew about
what an atom was, or maybe
they thought that there might
be such an atom but they had
never proved it, they were
dealing with these
macrostates.
They could measure pressure,
they could measure
temperature, they could
measure volume.
Now we know that that pressure
is due to things like, you
have a bunch of atoms
bumping around.
And let's say that this is a
gas-- it's a balloon- it's
going to be a gas.
And we know that the pressure is
actually caused-- and I've
done several, I think I did
the same video in both the
chemistry and the physics
playlist. I did them a year
apart, so you can see if my
thinking has evolved at all.
But we know that the pressure's
really due by the
bumps of these particles as they
bump into the walls and
the side of the balloon.
And we have so many particles
at any given point of time,
some of them are bumping into
the wall the balloon, and
that's what's essentially
keeping the balloon pushed
outward, giving it its pressure
and its volume.
We've talked about temperature,
as essentially
the average kinetic energy of
these-- which is a function of
these particles, which could
be either the molecules of
gas, or if it's an ideal gas,
it could be just the
atoms of the gas.
Maybe it's atoms of helium or
neon, or something like that.
And all of these things, these
describe the microstates.
So for example, I could describe
what's going on with
the balloon.
I could say, hey, you know,
there are-- I could just make
up some numbers.
The pressure is five newtons
per meters squared, or some
number of pascals.
The units aren't what's
important.
In this video I really
just want to make the
differentiation between these
two ways of describing
what's going on.
I could say the temperature
is 300 kelvin.
I could say that the volume
is, I don't know,
maybe it's one liter.
And I've described a system,
but I've described in on a
macro level.
Now I could get a lot more
precise, especially now that
we know that things like atoms
and molecules exist. What I
could do, is I could essentially
label every one of
these molecules, or let's say
atoms, in the gas that's
contained in the balloon.
And I could say, at exactly this
moment in time, I could
say at time equals 0, atom 1
has-- its momentum is equal to
x, and its position, in
three-dimensional coordinates,
is x, y, and z.
And then I could say, atom
number 2-- its momentum-- I'm
just using rho for momentum--
it's equal to y.
And its position is a, b, c.
And I could list every atom
in this molecule.
Obviously we're dealing with a
huge number of atoms, on the
order of 10 to the
20 something.
So it's a massive list I would
have to give you, but I could
literally give you the state of
every atom in this balloon.
And then if I did that, I
would be giving you the
microstates.
Or I would give you a specific
microstate of the
balloon at this time.
Now when a system-- and I'm
going to introduce a word
here, because this word is
important, especially as we
go-- is in thermodynamic
equilibrium.
So let me write that down.
Equilibrium.
We learned about equilibrium
from the
chemistry point of view.
And that tells you, that the
amount of something going into
forward reaction is equivalent
to the amount going in the
reverse reaction.
And when we talk about
macrostates, thermodynamic
equilibrium essentially
says that the
macrostate is defined.
That they're not changing.
If this balloon is in
equilibrium, at time 1 its
pressure, temperature, and
volume will be these things.
And if we look at it a second
later, its pressure,
temperature, and volume will
also be these things.
It's in equilibrium.
None of the macrostates
have changed.
And actually, I'll talk about
in a second, in order for
these macrostates to even be
defined, to be well defined,
you have to be in equilibrium.
I'll talk about that
in a second.
Now, at second number, at time
equals 0, you might have this
whole set of-- I went and
I listed 10 to the
20th-something microstates of
all the different atoms in
this molecule.
But then if I look at these
gases a second later, I'm
going to have a completely
different microstate right?
Because all of these guys are
going to have bumped into each
other, and given each other
their momentum.
And all sorts of crazy things
could have happened in a
second here, so I would have
a completely different
microstate.
So even though we're at
thermodynamic equilibrium, and
our macrostate stayed the same,
our microstates are
changing every gazillionth
of a second.
They're constantly changing.
And that's why, for the most
part, in thermodynamic, we
tend to deal with these
macrostates.
And actually most of
thermodynamics, or at least
most of what you'll learn in
a first-year chemistry or
physics course, it was devised
or it was thought about well
before people even had a sense
of what was going on at the
macro level.
That's often a very important
thing to think about.
And we'll go into concepts
like entropy and internal
energy, and things like that.
And you can rack your brain, how
does it relate to atoms?
And we will relate them to
atoms and molecules.
But it's useful to think that
the people who first came up
with these concepts came up
with them not really being
sure of what was going on
at the micro level.
They were just measuring
everything at the macro level.
Now I want to go back to this
idea here, of equilibrium.
Because in order for these
macrostates to be defined, the
system has to be
in equilibrium.
And let me explain
what that means.
If I were to take a cylinder.
And we will be using this
cylinder a lot, so it's good
to get used to this cylinder.
And it's got a piston in it.
And that's just, it's kind of
the roof of the cylinder can
move up and down.
This is the roof of
the cylinder.
The cylinder's bigger, but let's
say this is a, kind of a
roof of the cylinder.
And we can move this
up and down.
And essentially we'll just be
changing the volume of the
cylinder, right?
I could have drawn
it this way.
I could have drawn it
like a cylinder.
I could have drawn it like this,
and then I could have
drawn the piston like this.
So there's some depth here
that I'm not showing.
We're just looking at the
cylinder front on.
And so, at any point in time,
let's say the gas is between
the cylinder and the floor
of our container.
You know, we have a bunch of
molecules of gas here, a huge
number of molecules.
And let's say that we have
a rock on the cylinder.
We're doing this in space
so everything above
the piston is a vacuum.
Actually just let me erase
everything above.
Let me just erase this stuff,
just so you see.
We're doing this in space and
we're doing it in a vacuum.
Just let me write that down.
So all of this stuff up here is
a vacuum, which essentially
says there's nothing there.
There's no pressure from here,
there's no particles here,
just empty space.
And in order to keep this-- we
know already, we've studied it
multiple times, that this gas is
generating, you know things
are bumping into the wall,
the floor of this
piston all the time.
They're bumping into
everything, right?
We know that's continuously
happening.
So we would apply some pressure
to offset the
pressure being generated
by the gas.
Otherwise the piston
would just expand.
It would just move up and the
whole gas would expand.
So let's just say we stick a
big rock or a big weight on
top of-- let me do it in a
different color-- We put a big
weight on top of this piston,
where the force-- completely
offsets the force being
applied by the gas.
And obviously this is some force
over some area-- right,
the area of the piston-- over
some areas so that we could
figure out its pressure.
And that pressure will
completely offset the pressure
of the gas.
But the pressure of the gas,
just as a reminder, is going
in every direction.
The pressure on this plate is
the same as the pressure on
that side, or on that side, or
on the bottom of the container
that we're dealing with.
Now let's say that we were to
just evaporate this-- well
let's not say that we
evaporate the rock.
Let's say that we just evaporate
half of the rock
immediately.
So all of a sudden our weight
that's being pushed down, or
the force that's being pushed
down just goes to half
immediately.
Let me draw that.
So I have-- maybe I would be
better off just cut and
pasting this right here.
So if I copy and paste it.
So now I'm going to evaporate
half of that rock magically.
So let me take my eraser tool.
And I just evaporate
half of it.
And now what's going
to happen?
Well, this piston is now
applying half the force.
It can't offset the pressure
due to this gas.
So this whole thing is going
to be pushed upwards.
But I did it so fast. I did it
so fast. And you could try it.
I mean, this would be truth
of a lot of things.
If you had a weight hanging from
a spring, and you would
just remove half the weight, it
wouldn't just go very, you
know, nice and smoothly
to another state.
What's going to happen is--
and let me see if I can do
this using their cut and paste
tool-- it'll essentially,
right when I evaporate half of
it, the gas is going to expand
a bunch, and then this weight
is going to come back down,
it's going to spring
and go down.
So let me do it again.
It's going to expand, because
that gas is going to push up,
and then it's going
to come back down.
And then, it's just going to
oscillate a little bit.
And then eventually it'll come
back to some stable and maybe
it'll go back.
It'll look, like right
about there.
And let me fill this in.
This shouldn't be white,
it should be black.
Let me put some walls on
it, on the container.
So if we wait long enough,
eventually we'll get to
another equilibrium state, where
this thing, the piston
on top isn't, or the ceiling
isn't moving anymore.
And now the gas has filled
this container.
Now, at this point in time
we were in equilibrium.
The pressure throughout
the gas was the same.
The temperature throughout
The volume was in a
stable situation.
It wasn't changing from
second to second.
So because of that, our
macrostates were well defined.
Now, when we wait long enough,
this thing will get to some
stability where this
thing stops moving.
When this thing stops moving
our volume stops changing.
And hopefully our pressure will
start to become uniform
throughout the container.
And our temperature will
become uniform.
And we'll now be a higher volume
or lower pressure,
probably a lower temperature if
we assume that there's no
other heat being added
to the system.
And then we'll be well
defined again.
So we could say what the
pressure, and the volume, and
the temperature's going to be.
But what about right when
I removed this rock?
And this thing flew up and it
oscillated, and for a while
the pressure at the top
was lower than the
pressure down here.
Maybe the temperature at the
top was lower than the
temperature down here.
The whole thing was in
a state of flux.
It was not an equilibrium.
And at that point, when we're--
let me let me draw
that really-- so you know, when
we were in that state,
where everything was just
crazy, right when we
evaporated the rock.
You know, we have a little
rock up here.
Everything is going
up and down.
Maybe the pressure up here
was lower than the
pressure down here.
Everything did not have
a chance to reach an
equilibrium.
At this state-- and this is
important, especially as we go
into talking about things like
reversible reactions, and
reversible processes, and
quasi-static processes.
At this point in the reaction,
when we just did this, none of
these macrostates were
well defined.
You couldn't tell me what the
volume of this system is,
because it's changing for every
second to second, or
microsecond to microsecond,
it's fluctuating.
You couldn't tell me what the
pressure of the system is,
because it's changing
every second.
You couldn't tell me what
the temperature is.
Maybe the temperature could
be something there.
It could be something there.
All sorts of crazy things
are happening.
So when the system is in
a state of flux, your
macrostates are not
well defined.
And I really want to hit
that point home.
So me just draw that
in a diagram.
Let me draw that in
a PV diagram.
And we're going to use
these fairly heavily.
So on my y-axis I'm going
to put pressure.
In my x-axis I'm going
to put volume.
So our initial state here, when
we had the rock sitting
on top of the ceiling, this
movable ceiling or this
piston, maybe we had
some well-defined
pressure and volume.
So my y, this is pressure
and this is volume.
So this is where
we started off.
So it was well defined.
This is state 1.
Let me label it right there.
Now when we evaporated half the
rock, we eventually waited
long enough, and this got
to an equilibrium.
We got to state 2, and our
pressure volume and out
temperature was well defined.
And I'll just put it on
this pressure volume.
So maybe this is state 2.
We got down here.
And just as an aside, I could
maybe put temperature as an
extra dimension, but temperature
is completely
determined by pressure and
volume, especially if we're
dealing with an ideal gas.
Remember, and we did this in
multiple videos, you have PV
is equal to nRT.
These are constants.
The number of moles
isn't changing.
This is the universal gas
constant, not changing.
So if you know P and
V you know T.
So that's the only two things
we have to plot.
But I'll talk a lot more about
that in future videos.
But the important thing to
realize is, I started off at
this state, where pressure and
volume were well defined.
I finished in this state, where
pressure and volume were
well defined.
But how did I get there?
And because this reaction I
did, all of a sudden it
happened super fast, and it was
essentially thrown out of
equilibrium.
I don't know how I got here.
The pressure and volume were
not well defined from going
from that state to this state.
Pressure, volume, and
temperature are only well
defined if every intermediate
step is still almost in
equilibrium.
And we'll talk a lot more about
that in the next video.
But I want to really make
this point home.
It would be nice if we
could draw some path.
We could say, we moved from some
pressure and volume to
some other pressure and volume,
and we moved along a
well-defined path.
But we cannot say that.
Because when we went from there
there, our definitions
just disappeared for pressure
and volume.
We cannot define those
macrostates in these
intermediate non-equilibrium
states.
Now, just as a little aside,
we could have defined the
microstates.
The microstates never change.
At any given snapshot in time,
I could have listed every
particle that's in this thing.
And I could have given you
its kinetic energy.
I could have given
you its position.
you its momentum.
And there's no reason why I
couldn't have done that.
So I could have actually
made a plot of
one particular particle.
And I could have said what its
kinetic energy, and over a
course of time, is at any
given moment in time.
And this is really important.
So microstates are always
well defined.
The microstate is what's exactly
happening to the atom
in terms of its force and its
velocity and its momentum.
While macrostates are only
defined, I should say well
defined, when the system-- in
this case it's the balloon, in
this case it's this piston on
top of this cylinder, this
movable ceiling-- the
macrostates are only well
defined when the system is in
equilibrium, or when you can
essentially say, the pressure is
x, the pressure is the same
throughout.
Or the volume isn't changing
from moment to moment.
Or the temperature is the
same thing throughout.
Anyway, I'll leave you there and
we'll talk more about why
I went through all this pain
in the next video.